welcome to this video round six coverage
of the candidates tournament and the
game to analyze this video is to par off
against Kramnik yeah very important game
for the further cause of the tournament
of that's obvious from nick is playing
black to paul office on minus one he
needs to put some pressure and try to
get a win somewhere to get into the race
for for the first place everything else
is pretty much useless in this
tournament well Kramnik is on +1 and
it's basically okay the score he
certainly does not want to lose
especially not against his yeah against
against Apollo who's there they are
still not on speaking terms and don't
shake each other said hand and so on
which is quite understandable after the
events in 2006 and Alicia um it's okay
no so let's look at the game Queens
gambit declined yeah not a big surprise
kramnik is so playing that as his main
defense combined with the NIMS 0 against
g4 and took part off I mean okay I can
also play e4 certainly but really he
four against the berlin wall again yeah
so people very often go for d 4 against
chronic because they know that his
defenses against you for are so terribly
solid so mostly d4 spread look at our
naughty play d4 as well okay Bishop e7
the classical this time not the Vienna
variation or this invitation for the
slide that chronic played against aren't
he is playing Bishop e7 which is really
as main move the classical Bishop f4
also very much to be expected to pawn
off really has a terrible score with the
last covariation losing two crucial
games again
the honored in the World Championship
mentioned right after that in another
tournament it's a super solid line for
black so it's not really that they're
not so many players who are keen to try
to get something out of that and to pull
off really I mean if he wants to win a
game it's this game it's he needs a win
for the tournament and he certainly
wants to beat chronic like no other guy
on the planet so the ambition before as
the fighting move castles III nine
videos have everything to be expected
not be seven nowadays as the main line
of the bishop before Queens gambit and
ya hear the power of those 45 which I
personally always believed to be the
critical move in from a principal point
of view people have also tried many
other moves here a three for example age
three rook c1 this kind of moves against
all of that black is always going for c5
and we get this type of porn structure
it's only a matter of what white has
played its sometimes with the porn on a
three porn on h3 or any other move
basically what we get is an isolated
queen porn position where black
relatively quickly with moves like
Bishop g4 96 and Bishop f6 starts to
fight for the default square and very
often we get positions here that are
quickly simplified to draw gen games um
this is not integral of interest he
plays c5 the more aggressiveness and
also the move after which she has
obviously prepared something and we see
that right now after night h5 which is
some unexpected move Kramnik has played
this before in more than one game he
played Bishop to e5 which is almost the
novelty they're very little games with
that the normal way to play here's for
right to just allow the capture
and go for this structure leading to a
positional type of game where it's
questionable all right let's say I need
to I need to phrase it differently this
is the game type of game where black is
very close to equalise in the long run
but what can apply some pressure it's
not like black is shaking yeah and this
afraid of getting mated quickly but
still some problems to solve to Paula
forever once more he wants to really get
in a surprise so he plays the move
Bishop b5 and as he said after the game
it was meant to be a surprise for just a
single game as he don't believe that
this move is objectively so great um we
see a bit later why this might not be so
great but let's see c6 very normal move
black can consider are forced to take
the bishop but his rationality that you
can always take it and does not need to
do so right away um I guess that's a
fair point c6 and now Bishop d3 but
apart of very normal looking moves yeah
g6 plate back ronak still quickly plate
he's not like he was thinking too long
on that and this is a good Universal
move it protects the night which
sometimes can be a problem it protects
h7 in case of white ever initiating
something on this diagonal and it
provides a possible retweet square for
the night should it be attacked with g4
yeah this is all very normal looking and
now to pawn off quickly played the moves
H form and I believe here really early
we already have a critical position for
this game Kramnik now thought for a
while
and played f5 yeah look at this about 13
minutes and actually I'm surprised that
at this moment he he didn't capture on
e5 because after h4 I think this is
really the move to look at I can I can
show you some lines night xe5 I believe
that wide will probably take with the
night I'm d take c5 at first looks
completely ridiculous as you give up
this pawn but it still needs to be
checked briefly because our to the
bishop capture there is this idea and
this is not this is not entirely clear I
mean White has obviously made some
progress on the King side but on the
other hand you don't really feel like it
should be winning mating attack or
something like that it is it is may be
dangerous in a practical game it's very
hard to hard to evaluate the computer
prefers black but i wouldn't give so
yeah I wouldn't be so sure that this is
necessarily true White has really made
some progress on the kingside this is
not a silly idea d takes d5 it's a
something to consider um especially if
you look at the position after night xe5
which is the normal recapture certainty
after that I think that black can play
f6 and i'm not sure what happens after
that Knight f3 the simple kind of move
is just answered by e5 and here i'm
pretty sure that black is just better he
has gained the two bishops and now
pushed in the center it's not clear what
white is doing next move I mean II for
as a threat and the capture is certainly
good for black something like that
starts to look real silly for white what
is H for doing what is the light doing
it's simply a bad position
um yeah I believe that f6 the the thing
that probably has um yeah made kramnik
not playing the capture is 90 x g 6 and
this is indeed an interesting move and
something like that it's one possibility
where I'm not positive that yeah let's
say I don't know what to make out of
this position I mean I feel like black
must be okay but it's not really a
position that you probably would love to
play you are under tech and you know
that the opponent has prepared something
so yeah interesting Queen g4 is another
booth that might be might be interesting
something like that check and the H porn
is is coming coming down the board just
from my feeling yeah my intuition tells
me that this should be okay for black
but it's not something that you would
love to play in a practical game against
the part of where's prepared it so it's
understandable maybe that chronic is not
playing it but maybe it was also just
the principled way to go that's that's
possible after half five two parallel
plate I believe a good movie played
Bishop to H tube just retreating the
bishop from me five this is something
that it's very often very helpful that
white is just keeping this this this
Bishop yeah we add an interesting point
now from Nick played the moose b6 after
some thought um if you look at the
position there's a very simple question
that you can ask yourself what exactly
is happening if black is taking the pawn
it looks like the terribly materialistic
move I mean just grabbing this this age
for bond um but if you look at it i mean
when i watch the the live broadcast
I saw some of it I actually never
considered this it looks just about just
strange do to do to get this Bishop to
h4 I mean it's a pawn but it's still
looking like a strange move but in fact
if you analyze it I mean white has no
refutation in a way it cannot white
cannot play any great tactic or um sort
of yeah exploit this the situation here
on the H file with those funky pieces um
it seems that after that white is just
playing a like yeah like nothing has
happened and to play something like
before or Castle this is at least how
the computer approaches the position and
funny enough it gives white certain
advantage here like more than enough
compensation for porn which I find
personally quite amazing I I don't know
if I if you give me Blackie i I don't I
don't really think I would believe that
the other side has more than enough
compensation maybe he has some
compensation he's got good pieces and he
has a relatively easy plan but yeah in
advantage I don't know I understand
though what chronic didn't take it i
mean it's it's not very comfortable
position to play white as certainty um
yeah an easy to play game here so it
would have been principled just grab the
porn he played b6 would just in fact
them strategically normal move before
white must protect us poland's if I of
course yet here we add a position where
the capture is not possible actually
anymore as b5 as a strong reply after be
five black cannot take see success
getting yeah it's not getting ugly it's
just a lost position already the night
simply has nowhere to go
yeah okay you can kill here but well
here's your Bishop so this is not
possible but should be seven months be
played and then queen a4s just very
strong as after this this there is
simply the Queen being overloaded that
he must watch over the d7 night and age
for Bishop so this is loss of material
already yeah of course cone Nicki didn't
take he decided to play the move f4
which is yeah I know it's very committal
very committal pushing this pawn I mean
it it does one thing it limits the
bishop for the moment the bishop is not
an exceptionally great piece now but on
the other hand it's also jeff making i
don't know how to call it this is what's
a stone ball and now it is i know paper
wall it's it's very there are many
weaknesses of this move if you just
consider that at the later stage those
pawns will be exchanged against each
other after white is taking as taken
prolly then the six pole will get weak
c6 might be an issue so f4 is really a
very commitment move and probably not a
great one I don't really see how after a
forum Kramnik ISM is getting a really a
fine position anymore it seems that why
this is better after that the pile of
castles and now a five was played and a
five yeah to be honest after a five I
think black is lost I don't think you
can you can save the game after this
move but I'm not really sure what you
should play there are already lots of
problems with the various continuations
if you consider a very active move like
'if I've for example
certainly you move you you want to play
if you want to play actively but after
the capture here what has the strong
reply b5 very important and now he
undermines the center after be five from
why this yeah in excellent shape the
problem is you will get this pawn to c6
and how does black I'm ever going to to
win the pawn or play around it in a
decent fashion I don't see how a
normal-looking move like this is for
example answer publisher basics and you
don't really get anywhere Yemm why does
some it seems just better this is a
better than the game though but still
it's not it's not great yeah what about
solid solid moves like this I can do
that but look at that g4 night retreats
and h5 this kind of approach it looks a
bit insane but I mean you have played
age form and you might as well make some
sense out of that the problem is simply
that white has more pieces on the King
side or can switch more pieces to the
King side so g fo h5 is not weakening
white skin it's just a good attacking
attacking motif black should take for
instance there's quincy too and yeah
black is not going to go into survive
this just for argument's sake if you
look at yes and 95 yeah there's this
threat in the mix and something like
that white will quickly get the Queen
involved and just win with a king side
attack yeah I mean black ass it's really
not not great to play this position no
doubt about it
you know chronic went four for a five
and after be five which is entirely
logical yeah it's really a problem what
should black play now he took on on c5
but other moves yeah well they don't
they don't fare well as well we should
be seven for example white as I mean
more than one interesting continuation
but even if you just keep it simple like
take two times and click we need to why
does too threatening to take and take
only six and blacks position is just
it's just so weak here with those pawns
if you could play a f4 f4 f5 years black
you would actually improve your position
considerably I mean white still would be
better but with the Queen side open but
this is completely unplayable why term
is almost winning as he has no defense
to her to the capture if I if I was also
a substantial threat yeah so it's really
blackest in big trouble he took him and
after that dropped the night back yeah
it looks terrible to put the night back
on on bh but yeah where else to go if
you go to be 6 where exactly is the
snide heading a move like would be one
for example no no you can try something
like that but at the end there's always
this pawn black can never take as it
would open up the bishop and white has
ideas like Knight to e5 attacking too
many too many arrows like 95 attacking
the the night here or queen c295 taking
on g6 and black has no play at all he
always has this pawn to
that ties them up in comparison i think
from next move is better but it's the
terrible sight this poem on c6 that is
protected by the bishop yeah and after
those moves yeah this is probably the
relatively best chance you'd need to get
the pawn but there is a tactical issue
but there's no way anymore that Cromley
can avoid it he managed to get the c6
born but now there's night XD five it's
not like he overlooked this tactic it's
simply that black girl was some was in
an almost hopeless shape anywhere anyway
what what else are you playing here if
you not take on c5 yeah move like that
just a disaster what keeps this and the
whole position Quincy for coming yeah
amazingly bad position so Knight takes
d5 was allowed by black because of your
lack of alternatives took check I know
why took on 16 yeah and from being upon
down white is now one material after
this trade black could have taken on
everyone but it's not really a helping
much white can take the rook here and
after this retreat just keep the bishop
yeah in the game we had something
something similar actually like God got
this porn but white give it was able to
gain the a 5-1 check this is all quite
normal and yeah now we have an end game
with white having the B porn extra and
this is obviously a great pawn to have I
mean it's it's supported by this this
type of Bishop on h2 so black it's
basically VI in hopeless condition here
and it's very simple technical play but
why just rupee one to support the porn
check yeah check now chat and get what
you don't need to be rated 2802 to win
this game why does just just pushing his
born check yeah idea he's attacking this
this night from the side there's no way
to stop the porn anymore Blackie goes
back here right Jess the lonely well
somebody give this check and promote
next move Jay give get some checks and
after King III resigned the game it's
impossible to to stop the beat born
simply yeah a very very tough loss for
Chrome dick and yeah i'm not sure i mean
the the Russian um the Russian language
commentator for the official site said
that this basically ends chrome Knicks
ambitions in this tournament yeah maybe
it does maybe it does i mean it's it's
really he's on fifty percent now which
is not not brilliant in itself but the
way the game went is really really a
devastating especially considering that
he lost like that against a pawn off on
I mean he also would have been less than
enthusiastic if this would have been
against a friend of him like a like a
like I garnet or whatever but it's it's
simply a devastating loss yeah intim
yeah well maybe he still has a chance
now in fifty percent it's not the end of
the world it's just one point behind
Arnold at least their father round on a
thousand plus two um yeah and two part
of his back in the in the race I mean if
you say that he's back in the race why
shouldn't kramnik be still in it
to pull off now and fifty percent he
bounced back from this loss and
certainly this is a wind that might yeah
boost his confidence as he managed to
beat his archrival yeah and it was it
was a good game certainly he got in an
interesting open preparation I guess the
real the real crisis in this game was
very very early even after this I mean
probably around here it is where black
needs to improve after a five really
quickly I think we come to a point where
blacks position probably was what's
beyond repair and yeah I mean I believe
that really chronic has some maybe some
psychological issues if it many places
to power off I don't know it's it's
obviously not a normal game for for both
players because of the the events back
in two thousand six but it feels like
chrome leg is affected more by that this
was also stated by commentators during
the game and I thought about that and
maybe this is really the case I mean
it's very unconscious uncharacteristic
of him to have so many weaknesses
afterthought he moves just look at the
position and he has some so many porns
that are weak c6e six the whole position
is full of weaknesses he has a
decentralized night and normally his
players really am a display of harmony
and somehow I don't know him is may be
distracted by this this this negative
end and tense atmosphere that he has
many placer against Apollo of people
react differently to to situation where
they play someone they've really dislike
I mean there they are very young they're
people that are absolutely not affected
at all they're just play a normal game
but I know I mean I personally I like to
play against
people that I like i don't know i mean
it feels good to me and i am i'm more
creative and if i play someone I really
don't like so much it sometimes really
it affects me negatively i don't know
how exactly but it's not helpful to me
so contrary to what what what Fisher
said that he really needs to dislike the
opponent and wants to crush him and this
kind of stuff um it's um it's not
necessary really to to fear that kind of
things towards your opponent yeah well
it's hard to hard to say this is all
like amateur psychology of
psycho-analysis something like that okay
so I've nevertheless an interesting game
and they hope you like the coverage of
it thanks for watching